♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FORMER
PRESS SECRETARY SEAN SPICER WAS
ON "DANCING WITH THE STARS" THIS
SEASON.
A LOT OF PEOPLE COMPLAINED ABOUT
HIM BEING THERE, BUT HE MADE IT
A LONG TIME.
EIGHT WEEKS, I THINK.
HE RECEIVED SUPPORT FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
HERE'S A LOOK AT HIM DANCING
LAST NIGHT.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: SEAN SPICER JOINS
US TONIGHT.
YOU DID WHAT YOU NEEDED TO DO.
YOU WENT ALL IN.
YOU ARE SAVAGE.
I LOVE THAT.
YOU LASTED ABOUT FIVE TIMES AS
LONG AS ANYONE PREDICTED THAT
YOU WOULD.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THE
EXPERIENCE?
>> HONESTLY, I HAD A BLAST.
I REALLY, REALLY ENJOYED THIS,
IT EXCEEDED MY EXPECTATIONS.
I WENT INTO THIS THINKING ONE,
TWO WEEKS, MAY BECOME I'M NOT
REALLY GOOD AT THIS.
BUT I WILL HAVE FUN, I WILL
LEARN SOMETHING.
I MADE IT TO THE QUARTERFINALS
OF THIS SHOW.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> I HAD A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, DON JR., SO MANY
FOLKS THAT CAME OUT.
JESSE WATTERS.
SO MANY FOLKS THAT ARE FRIENDS
AND SUPPORTERS, AND MADE THIS
JOURNEY SO MUCH FUN, BUT I LOVE
BEING PART OF THE SHOW.
IT WAS A GREAT EXPERIENCE, AND I
THINK I'M BETTER FOR IT.
>> Tucker: TOM BERGERON IS ONE
OF THE HOST, GROWTH IS KIND OF,
I THOUGHT, KIND OF CONTEMPTIBLE
COMPLAINT, BASICALLY ABOUT YOU
GOING ON THE SHOW.
YOU DIDN'T TAKE OFFENSE.
YOU DECIDED NOT TO HOLD A
GRUDGE.
YOU ACTED LIKE IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
YOU WERE TOTALLY NICE.
YOU JUST KEPT GOING AND REMAIN
POSITIVE.
HAVE TO SAY, I WAS IMPRESSED BY
THAT.
WAS IT HARD TO REMAIN POSITIVE
WHILE HE WAS SNIPING AT YOU?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IF NOT THE
FIRST TIME THAT SOMEBODY HAS
MADE NEGATIVE COMMENTS ABOUT ME.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
GOOD POINT.
>> WHAT I WOULD RATHER DO IS
LEAD BY AND SHOW BY EXAMPLE.
WHAT I THINK I DEMONSTRATED IS
THAT WE CAN BRING A DIVERSE
GROUP OF PEOPLE TOGETHER.
I LOVE SUPPORTING CONSERVATIVE
PRINCIPLES.
AND BEING A REPUBLICAN, I'M
PROUD ABOUT THAT.
BUT I THINK I WANT US, OUR SIDE
TO BE BETTER THAN THEIR SIDE,
AND COME TOGETHER AND SHOW
PEOPLE THAT WE CAN FIGHT IT OUT
ON PRINCIPLES AND POLICIES, BUT
THE GOOD PEOPLE, COME TOGETHER,
AND I THOUGHT WHAT THIS SHOW
DOES SO WELL IS BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER, SUPPORT EACH OTHER,
ROUTE FOR EACH OTHER, LEAVE ALL
OF THE REST OF THAT STUFF ASIDE,
AND FOR TWO HOURS ONCE A WEEK,
EVERYONE GETS TO BE ON
EVERYBODY'S TEAM AND CHEER FOR
EACH OTHER.
>> Tucker: AND YOU DID THAT.
I MEAN, YOU REFUSED TO LIVE DOWN
TO THEIR EXPECTATIONS OF YOU.
YOU REFUSED TO EMBODY THEIR
ATTACKS ON YOU.
YOU WERE RELENTLESSLY CHEERFUL
TO THE LAST MINUTE, NO MATTER
WHAT THEY SAID OR DID.
AND I JUST THOUGHT, THAT'S AN
INSPIRATION TO PEOPLE.
WHAT DID TRUMP SAY WHEN YOU
TALKED TO HIM LAST NIGHT?
>> WELL, I CALLED HIM.
HE HAS BEEN SUPER SUPPORTIVE OF
ME SINCE I LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND PARTICULARLY THE LAST NINE
WEEKS.
I CALLED HIM TO JUST EXPRESSED
TO HIM MY APPRECIATION FOR HIS
CONTINUED SUPPORT.
THE VOTES ARE WHAT KEPT ME IN
THIS.
MY JUDGES SCORES IN MY DANCE
MOVES WERE NOT EXACTLY THE
HIGHEST AND MACCABEE SCORE, SO I
WANTED TO SHOW HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATED WHAT HE AND HIS
FAMILY DID COME ALL OF HIS
SUPPORTERS, FOR KEEPING ME IN TE
CITY FOR NINE WEEKS.
>> Tucker: UNBELIEVABLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE HAS EVER
MARSHALED THE SUPPORT OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
ARE YOU FINALLY COMING BACK TO
WASHINGTON?
EVEN LIVING IN A HOTEL IN L.A.
FOR NINE MONTHS.
SPEAK I THINK GOD ALWAYS HAS A
PLAN.
TOMORROW IS MY 15TH ANNIVERSARY
TO MY BEAUTIFUL WIFE, REBECCA,
WHO WAS MY NUMBER ONE CHAMPION.
SO I GET TO BE HOME FOR MY
ANNIVERSARY, IT MEANS NOT GOT TO
FIND A GIFT REAL QUICK.